okay first let's go over some wrong ways
to use in some spirometer a lot of times
if patients haven't been
properly they will do what they think
you're supposed to do naturally with it
by blowing into the device rather than
actually inhaling from the device
another wrong way patients may try to
use in sims from--it ER is by quickly
inhaling and exhaling off the device
like this now let's look at the right
way to use incentive spirometer okay
first what you want to do is you want to
set the goal for the patient with the
yellow marker so they know where they
need to get whenever using this instead
of spirometer then you're going to have
the patient set up and exhale completely
then have them seal their mouth around
the mouthpiece tightly and they will
inhale slowly and deeply making sure to
keep the yellow indicator on the side
within normal range they don't want that
little yellow piece to go too high or
too low and as they do this the piston
will rise up and have the patient keep
inhaling as deep as possible until they
can't inhale anymore and then they'll
need to hold the breath for six seconds
and then exhale slowly and allow the
piston to fall before repeating again
and record the amount that they were
able to get on incentive spirometer and
they will perform this at least ten
times every hour to wile away so this is
what it looks like in action